اذا مشاهدينا فوز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وراءه شبكه عمرها عقدا بحسب
فاينانشي تايمز البريطانيه الصحيفه قالت
ان نفوذ الدوله وسخائها يفسران شعبيه
الرئيس التركي لدى الناخبين وارتباط
الكثير منهم بحزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم
فانز اضافت ان الدعم الحكومي يضع الملايين
في موقف يخافون معه من رئاسه دون اردوغان
على سدتها نقلت الصحيفه عن خبراء قولهم ان
عدد فئات تعتمد على بقاء حزب العداله
والتنميه في السلطه لمواصله تلقي الفوائد
من الدوله ووفق فاينانشي تايمز دائما تمتد
الشبكات القويه التي اقامها حزب العداله
والتنميه الى الاعمال التجاريه وذلك
بتقديم العطاءات والفرص للمجموعات القريبه
من الحزب ورجاله كما ان الحزب قام بتوظيف
العديد من اقارب اعضائه في مناصب رفيعه في
الادارات في المنظمات غير ايضا في
الجامعات والبلديات ورغم ذلك وصف عضو في
العداله والتنميه ما ذكر بانه دعايه من
المعارضه واعتبر ان الحزبه تمكن عبر سنوات
من كسب معاقل انتخابيه تاريخيه لاحزاب
كبيره ايضا كما اكد هذا العضو ان الحزب
استخدم شبكته الكبيره للبقاء على اتصال
دائم مع المؤيدين والذين قد يدعمون الحزب
في مرحله ما في تايمز ختم تقريرها بالقول
ان الفوائد الفعليه لدعم حزب العداله
والتنميه لا تقتصر على الوظائف الحكوميه
بل تصل للمساعدات الاجتماعيه لكبار السن
والفقراء والاغاثه في حالات الكوارث دائما
نحن مستمرون مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
لنتائج الانتخابات وخاصه بعد اعلان الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان رسميا رئيسا لتركيا لمده
خمس سنوات لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات